це є агресія Росії по відношенню до
україні
незаконно відібрали крим думали що таким
ж шляхом про нього і можуть відібрати Донбас
і не тільки донбас а мріє
полагодить всю всю Україну і не тільки
україну ж мріють повернути свою під
свій вплив
колишні держави соціалістичного
табори
тобто прибалтійські всій республіці не
польшу румунію болгарію, тобто
державі яким входили
соціалістичну систему ось путін про
цьому мріє, але марно він мріє
тому що період імперії закінчився
імперії вже у світі не буде ми живемо у
глобалізованому світі в якому імперії
ні і мріяти про те, щоб повернути
період імперії це марна праця
[музика]
впливова
на українську церкву він не може
намагається вплинути на Україну через
українську церкву московського
патріархату ось це він намагається і він на
це розраховував що завдяки ось цій
так звана українська православна
церква московського патріархату
він підпорядкує собі україну думав так не
розрахував сили тому що існує
київський патріархат
а одні й річ не тільки в київському
патріархаті on
український народ волелюбну не хоче
більше підкорятися Москві
[музика]
по-перше ми належимо до сім'ї
слов'янських народів це одне означає це
вже нас зближує
по-друге, ми не протягом століть жили
або як сусіди або абияк одне
держава і тому ми зблизилися ми
брати і тому повинні жити як брати
але брат не повинен поневолювати свого
брата
якщо вибрати ожини як брати
вони як пан і раб а путін хоче
повернути нас у рабство яким ми були
все знаєте стане на своє місце тобто
війна припиниться